كان السؤال الذي يدور في أذهان الجميع
في المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في دافوس عام
2000 ، من هو السيد.  بوتين في ذلك الوقت كان
العالم يعرف القليل عن فلاديمير
بوتين الرجل الذي أصبح رئيسًا بشكل غير متوقع
عشية رأس السنة الجديدة 1999
كان بوتين قد لفت الانتباه الدولي بالفعل
كرئيس سابق للوزراء بوريس
يلتسين من خلال حديثه القاسي
حول محاربة الإرهابيين المحليين ولكن
لم يُعرف الكثير عن ذلك.  رجل أو
حياته الشخصية التي تخضع لحراسة مشددة ، دخل بوتين ، وهو
مواطن من لينينغراد ، السياسة بعد أن كان
يعمل في المخابرات السوفيتية
المخيفة كان يعمل كجاسوس في
ألمانيا الشرقية قبل سقوط جدار برلين ،
وكان ظهوره الأول على
المسرح الدولي لم يكن مصقولًا  في
مقابلة مبكرة مع لاري كينج من CNN ،
بدا أن الرئيس الجديد كاد يبتسم
عندما سُئل عن الغرق
المأساوي لغواصة Kursk العسكرية الروسية ،
فأخبرني بما حدث مع
الغواصة التي أغرقت آلة العلاقات العامة في الكرملين ،
لكن كان عازمًا على إعادة تشكيله في
التلفزيون الحكومي  صوره على أنه زعيم قوي
يظهره في مظاهر مكتوبة بإحكام على
أنه لروسيا
القائد الأعلى للقوات المسلحة وكشخصية على
المسرح العالمي ، تم تشكيل صورة بوتين
بعناية لتصويره على
أنه زعيم دولة صاعدة
نهضت من ركبتيها بعد
الانهيار المهين للاتحاد
السوفيتي وفقدانه مكانة القوة العظمى وشعب
بوتين.  لم يكن هناك مجال
للضعف ، حيث تم تصوير زعيم الكرملين
في مجموعة من المظاهر على أنه
رجل رجل كمدافع عن الحيوانات
وقبل كل شيء كوطني عاطفي تقريبًا
، حتى أن صورته الاستبدادية الصارمة كانت موضع
حسد من قبل القادة الطموحين الآخرين في عام 2013 ،
تساءل دونالد ترامب عما إذا كان  سيصبح بوتين
أفضل صديق له في الاقتباس للعديد من
الروس ، لقد أصبح بوتين تجسيدًا
لمكانة روسيا الوطنية ، لكن
يبقى السؤال ما الذي يأتي بعده
بعد عقدين في السلطة حيث خرج الآلاف
إلى الشوارع في موسكو في أواخر
يوليو للمطالبة بإجراء انتخابات حرة ونزيهة.
كان بوتين متجهًا إلى قاع
البحر في الغواصة التي كانت بالنسبة لبعض
النقاد رمزًا
لقائد قوي بعيد المنال.  شعبه
ناثان هودج سي إن إن موسكو